is Google doing creepy things to us a
new documentary says yes Google crosses
the creepy line every day before I
explain the creepy line let's review how
we got here
Alison can you explain what internet is
just a few decades ago a time when
people my age didn't understand
computers mark zuckerberg who was a
student at Harvard decided he wanted to
create a social media platform basically
to meet girls and to make friends we
were college students right and we're
just building stuff because we thought
it was cool Larry Page and Sergey Brin
decide they wanted to create the
ultimate search engine for the Internet
they had a better index than other
indexes that were around theirs was not
the first search engine it was just
leaps and bounds ahead of services like
Yahoo Alta Vista and quickly became the
clear winner in the space just from a
technology basis Google put answers to
your question on one page and rank them
spiders around the internets taking
pictures of web pages and analyzing the
links between the web pages and using
that to make some assumptions about
relevance now they had to figure out how
do we make money off this all you do is
track people searches your search
history is very very informative that's
gonna tell someone immediately whether
you're Republican or Democrat whether
you like one breakfast cereal versus
another then they could sell you to
advertisers so they could hook up the
umbrella makers with people searching
for umbrellas basically sends you
targeted ads that is where Google gets
more than 90% of its revenue they don't
sell you anything they sell you fine
because they know about me I get ads on
my screen that might actually appeal to
me so what's the problem
well the filmmaker says this is the
problem they are constructing a profile
of you and that profile is real it's
detailed it's granular and it never goes
away and what I didn't know until I
watch the creepy line is how far Google
goes to follow us on the web they were
getting a lot of information from people
using the search engine
but if people went directly to a website
uh-oh that's bad because now Google
doesn't know that so they developed a
browser which is now the most widely
used browser in the world Chrome by
getting people to use Chrome they were
able now to collect information about
every single website you visited whether
or not you were using their search
engine but of course even that's not
enough right then Google wanted to know
what do people do when they're not only
one as soon as you connect to the
internet
Android uploads to Google a complete
history of where you've been that day so
what they're given me information they
are giving you information but to the
extent that somebody can do something
for you they can do something to you
Peter Schweitzer wrote the creepy line I
love these services well you're seeing
all the positive good side of it what's
your movies all about the bad side
that's why people hate the media the
question comes down to are they abusing
their power and I think you can make a
very important powerful compelling case
that they are his documentary suggests
regulation media companies are regulated
newspapers are regulated
telecommunications providers are
regulated but regulation often makes
things worse for consumers and
politicians are too clueless to do it
well
watch senator hatch embarrass himself
well how do you sustain a business model
in which users don't pay for your
service
senator we run ads you want regulation
that's gonna make it better I think one
of the ways you deal with Google's
market concentration and its massive
control of search has put it under the
same shackles that other media companies
shackles aren't good a government has
the guns government can always step in
at some point if the people find Google
just doing evil yeah but to start it now
I would rather say here are the ground
rules that other media companies have to
subscribe to Google should be put in the
same category now I don't presume to
know what if anything ought to be done
to make sure Facebook and Google don't
harm the world but the documentary does
make a compelling case that these giant
companies do creepy things there's what
I call the creepy line and the Google
policy about a lot of these things is to
get right up for the creepy line but not
cross it it's an interesting word creepy
right because it's a it's a word that
connotes horror I don't think the
typical ethical person says I'm going to
push right up to the line of creepy and
stop there here because creepy is really
bad a creepy mugger is worse than a
mugger the mugger wants your money god
only knows what the creepy mugger wants
it's more than your money in my second
and concluding video on the creepy line
we look at how a few people in Silicon
Valley secretly shape what we think and
maybe who will govern us I am running
for president last election Silicon
Valley tried but failed to elect Hillary
but next election the creepy line says
if the major players in tech right now
and that's mainly Google and Facebook
banded together and got behind the same
candidate they could shift 10% of the
vote in the United States no one knowing
that they had done anything